how did you get into collecting art oh
that's really really interesting i
didn't know you used your eyes no
selena gomez is trolling her only
murders in the building co-stars and
it's so good and i love it the actress
is back in action with steve martin and
martin short filming season two of their
hit hulu series and while sitting on set
selena decided to playfully troll the
comedic legends on tick tock how did you
get into collecting art oh that's really
really interesting because i started
very very young
and i used my eyes to look at art i
didn't know you used your eyes
yep that's selena giving a major eye
roll to martin and steve the singer
added the caption quote day one back
with these dads
let's watch it again i thought you kind
of felt it and sensed it right so that's
just with a live model
now it's all love between the cast
because this isn't the first time selena
has gotten her co-stars to join in on
her tick tock fun okay so what are we
just talking about
no you don't hit the g like that it's
not g-e-e oh yeah oh geez
[Laughter]
we're the ogs
yep those og's are learning a thing or
two from selena on set i'm officially
the third
amiga i should say yeah back in august
e.t spoke with the trio about filming
the series and the guys shared how
selena kept them hip on all things pop
culture you know she tells steve lyrics
to wwe
what kong's
songs
wait selena did you explain [ __ ] to them
i certainly why can't you say wap
because that's not what they say that's
not what the kids that's like calling
the usa usa
selena what up thank you for this
service selena for explaining and did
you what did you guys think when you
learned the meaning of wap
well i you know i i i've known it for
years
[Music]